[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let me now introduce
you to Feryal Ozel,
who is a professor of astronomy
and astrophysics in astronomy.
She has made pioneering
contributions
to the physics of neutron
stars and black holes
as well as the co-evolution
of black holes and galaxies
in the universe.
Feryal is a fellow of the
American Physical Society,
current Guggenheim fellow.
She received the Maria Goeppert
Mayer Award from the American
Physical Society, the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study
Fellowships, the Bart
Bok Prize from Harvard,
and the Miller Institute
Professorship from Berkeley.
She serves on a large
number of committees
for NASA and the National
Science Foundation.
She's a chair of the Science
and Technology Definition Team
for NASA's next large x-ray
mission concept in Lynx.
And she frequently appears
in TV documentaries
on PBS, BBC, and
the History Channel.
Please, welcome Feryal Ozel.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Good evening.
It's very nice to see
so many of you here.
And that guitar performance
is hard to follow.
But I'm hoping to do
my best and take you
on a journey tonight with
me for the next 45 minutes
or so to what we
call the extreme.
So extreme places in the
universe, extreme places
in astrophysics
where you might think
science meets science fiction,
is this really science?
Are you sure you're
really an astrophysicist?
And I'm going to
ask questions like,
what makes up the
cores of neutron stars?
Don't worry if you don't know
what a neutron star is right
now or you're not sure exactly
what a black hole is right now.
Hopefully by the end of the
talk, you will know these.
And more importantly,
maybe we'll
be able to answer
the questions like,
what particles make up the
cores of neutron stars?
What is the dividing line
between more or less matter
as we know it, even
if it is in a state
that we don't
recognize on Earth,
and what we call a singularity,
where black holes appear?
And are black holes
really what we predict?
Do they really have event
horizons that cut them off
from the rest of the universe?
So these might be some
far-fetched questions,
but really there are
underlying reasons
why we ask these questions.
For example, we want to know
if our theories of physics
fail somewhere.
We can design experiments.
We can think of mathematical
frameworks in which we
explore physics, and we try to
push it to their boundaries.
And the universe provides
us with ample places where
we can actually really
push that frontier and say,
do they break somewhere?
Is there something
else that appears
that we don't know of yet?
Do they contradict each other?
We have different
physics theories
that describe the
subatomic, like you
heard in Keith Dienes' lecture
last week if you were here--
and I will introduce it
again a little bit today--
and gravity that acts on the
scales of stars and galaxies
and the entire universe.
Is there ever a
tension between these,
and can we exploit
that tension in order
to further our understanding
of physical reality?
And other questions like,
what experimental evidence
do we have for the physical
theories that we write down
here, mathematically
formulae, because physics
after all is based on evidence.
It is based on facts that
are based on experiments.
So whatever we can
think of, we would
like to see it in
order to believe it.
We would like
quantitative data in order
to really move forward.
So this is going to be the
backbone of my lecture.
As we move to the brink
of a black hole, the edge
of a black hole, going from a
neutron star to a black hole,
can we break our theories?
It might sound weird,
but that's actually
something that excites me.
So before we go too far
down that rabbit hole,
though, let me bring
you back to Earth,
where we know what
atoms are made of.
And we can test a lot of
our theories experimentally.
So this is where
Keith Dienes left off,
the building blocks of normal
matter, where we know matter
is made up of atoms
with nuclei that
carry most of the mass and a
cloud of electrons around them
that make up most of the volume.
So anything from water to one of
the densest elements on Earth,
platinum, just has
this structure.
And platinum and water differ by
density by only a factor of 20.
You might think 20 is large.
Just wait.
So under these
circumstances, there
are protons and neutrons
that make up matter.
Now there are places
in the universe where
we start crushing matter
further and further
under the weight of gravity.
And at that point,
the electrons that
make up the bulk
of the volume get
pushed into the nucleus
and start combining
with the protons, making more
and more neutron-rich matter.
So at that point, we
have, if you will,
a neutron soup that
is still in some ways
reminiscent of the nucleus.
It's just that the
density has increased
by a very large factor.
All the electrons are
now in the nucleus,
and this matter that we
call neutron matter is now
extremely dense.
Now there is a question
that we cannot answer by any
experimental evidence on Earth.
Even when you make
neutrons matter and make it
this extremely dense
stuff, we still
think that the quarks, the
constituents of both protons
and neutrons in normal
matter, might remain bound.
We've never seen a free quark.
If we keep on squeezing
matter further and further,
the free quarks appear.
So can we ever reach
a form of matter
that we've never seen before?
And does this happen
in the universe?
So think of taking
a bunch of grapes
and squeezing them further
and further and further.
As one of my colleagues
likes to say,
eventually you will
get grape juice.
So can we get to that point
somewhere in the universe where
we've squeezed matter so
hard that the constituents
of protons and
neutrons have broken up
to their original form,
which is free quarks?
So when I put this on some
line going from normal matter,
at lower density with
its electrons around,
to neutron matter, is
there this next step
made up of free quarks?
So from here to
here, take a guess
as to how many factors of 10
we have increased in density.
Remember, from
water to something
like iron or platinum,
it's a factor of 20 2-0.
From here to neutron
star cores where
we think this matter appears,
it is a factor of 100 trillion.
That's why we can't
make it on Earth.
We can temporarily form matter.
We can probe the constituents
of the nuclei of atoms
by smashing particles
together like Elliott Cheu is
going to talk to you about.
But that's a very
temporary state of matter.
We can't make it
sustained, and therefore we
can't say if there is a stable
form of matter that actually
is made up of free quarks.
That we can only do if
we find the right places
in the universe where
gravity comes to our help
because whatever
we can do on Earth
is limited by the
amount of force
that we can apply
to the particles.
But out there in the
universe, our sun, which
is a pretty ordinary star--
I know we don't
like to hear that.
But it's actually
kind of a wimpy star.
Imagine the amount
of crushing force
it can apply inward to
every bit of that star.
There are stars that are 300
times the mass of our sun.
So gravity plays a huge
role in shaping everything
that we see in the universe.
And in that state, we
think stable configurations
of this dense matter that
is 100 trillion times more
dense, that a teaspoonful would
weigh as much as a mountain,
can actually occur.
This just means more matter
packed into a smaller volume,
so that's how much
it would weigh.
In order to understand
what type of settings
would allow us to
reach that, let's just
think for a second of how
stars spend their lives.
Actually, stars
spend their lives
fighting against this inward
pull of gravity, this crushing
force that they feel
just by their own weight,
the walls trying to
collapse onto them.
But stars, during
their regular lives,
produce a lot of energy--
produced heat, light
through nuclear reactions,
combining hydrogen into
helium, helium into carbon.
That's what generates the
energy that holds a star up.
So a star is always a fight
between the inward pull
of gravity and the
outward push of pressure.
During their lifetimes,
this pressure
is always equal to the
gravity, and it always
comes from the fusion
reactions that take place
at the cores of these stars.
But a star has a
finite amount of fuel.
Eventually, it will go
through all of its elements,
fusing them, and run out
of the source of energy.
When that happens, it starts
actually collapsing and losing
that pressure support that it
has enjoyed through its life
and gets to a point where
gravity seems to be winning.
So at this point,
when all these atoms
are squeezed against
one another and turned
into this neutron-rich matter
that I was telling you about,
there are two options.
Either those neutrons,
pushing against one another,
are going to win and
stop the collapse.
And we will end up
with a neutron star.
Or they will lose this
fight, and the walls
will come crushing down
on the entire star.
And we will end
up with something
that shrinks
infinitely to the core,
and we will end up
with a black hole.
So thinking back to the
very first questions
that I tried to present to you,
as far as rethinking reality,
I said, do our
physical theories fail?
And do they
contradict each other?
This is an excellent place
to look because you've
pushed gravity to its extreme.
You've pushed your understanding
of particles to its extreme.
And they are in this fight
for their lives basically.
So it's that interface that I've
been studying for the last 20
years or so.
Ever since I was a
graduate student,
I have been fascinated
with what happens
if the outcome is a
neutron star, what happens
if the outcome is a black hole.
So let's go a
little bit further.
First, follow the first
path that I just mentioned,
which is let's say that the
neutrons that are formed
can stop the collapse.
But there are still
those nagging questions.
Is it just neutrons, or do we
actually encounter free quarks
in that advanced state?
How do we answer that question?
So it turns out even
though they are tiny--
they are give or take
15 miles across--
and even though they
are very distant--
so take the size
of a city that's
much smaller than
Tucson, and put it
at astronomical
distances where we
can't send probes
to actually find out
what's in the interior--
it turns out that neutron stars
aren't very shy about revealing
what's in their interior.
And the reason for
this is the following.
If the interior
is pure neutrons,
like in the first case
that I showed you,
it turns out they can withstand
a little bit more pressure
if they don't dissolve into
their quark constituents
and can make stars that are
a little bit bigger in size
and a little bit
heavier, more massive.
Whereas if they do dissolve
into their core constituents
and become some sort of a
quark star or a hybrid star,
then they can not
support as much mass.
And they tend to
be smaller in size.
What we've been trying
to do is measure
the sizes of neutron stars and
the masses of neutron stars
to see if they look more
like this or more like this.
Now these are tiny objects, very
massive, but tiny and far away.
So again, we can't send probes.
We can't go near them.
We'll have to use the light
that's emitted by them
and reach our telescopes
either on Earth or in orbit
around the Earth in
satellites in order
to answer this question.
So what do we do?
We weigh them.
It's not that hard.
How do we weigh the sun?
We don't go there with a scale.
What we do is follow
the motions of things
that are orbiting the
sun, in our case planets,
and apply the same
principles to things
that are orbiting a neutron
star and use Kepler's laws.
Kepler wrote down these laws
several hundred years ago,
and it works.
This could be another
neutron star orbiting
around the neutron star.
This could be a normal star
orbiting around the neutron
star, but the same
principle will apply.
So we weigh them.
How big are they?
Can they have quark cores, or
do they have neutron cores?
And we measure their sizes.
Again, sort of like a
ruler, but what we really do
is collect all the light
that comes from the sun.
This is, again, very similar
to what we do for normal stars.
We separate that light
into its components,
into different wavelengths,
and form a spectrum.
And the combination of the total
light emitted by the neutron
star and the breakdown
of that light
into its elements,
the spectrum, gives us
an exact measure of the size
that is emitting that light.
So this is a
technique that we use.
And in the past few years, we've
actually made a breakthrough
in this technique, both
because of more sophisticated
calculations and better data
that we were able to obtain.
And so far all the data that we
have points to smaller stars,
so something more like
12 miles across as
opposed to more like
18 miles across.
We can tell the difference.
It's mind boggling that
these faraway objects can
differ by such small amounts and
yet we can tell the difference.
But they turn out to
be the smaller kind.
So what we think is happening
with the current data
is that free quarks
most likely appear
in the cores of neutron stars.
If this result holds,
if we subject it
to many independent
tests, find other ways
of weighing them and
measuring their sizes,
and we believe our
result at the end,
it would be the first time
anywhere in the universe
that we have evidence
for a state of matter
that is made up of free quarks.
The second thing that
this result tells us,
all the data that
we've gathered,
is that anything that's more
massive than about twice
the mass of our sun is bound
to collapse into a black hole.
So there is no stable neutron
star configuration or quark
star configuration
that will hold up
anything against collapse that
is more massive than about
twice the mass of our sun.
So the regime we are
in is that we have now
pushed matter,
squeezed matter down so
much that nothing can stop
its collapse against gravity.
So what happens?
I said in that diagram,
a black hole forms,
but I haven't really
introduced black holes to you.
In order to do that, I'm
going to take a tiny detour
and talk a little bit
more about gravity
and tell you why black holes
are inevitable in our current
understanding of gravity.
So, of course, in
order to do that,
we go to our friend,
Albert Einstein,
who is one of the people who
rethought reality in many ways,
in almost all of
his contributions.
But probably the
most phenomenal one
is when he rethought gravity.
Any other force, any other
interaction in physics,
we write it down as a
force between particles
and interactions that take
place between two particles.
Until Einstein
came along, when we
had Newton's
formulation of gravity,
the same thing was true.
Gravity was an interaction
between two masses,
and that's how Newton's
theory was formulated.
However, when you look
at Newton's theory,
it's actually incompatible
with the special theory
of relativity, which
Einstein had worked
out several years earlier.
So he thought, hmm.
These two theories contradict.
That is a great place to look.
When your physical theories that
have been individually tested
start conflicting
with each other,
the discovery potential
there is huge.
And that's exactly what
Einstein used in order
to rethink our
understanding of gravity.
And what he said is that
actually gravity is not a force
at all.
Gravity is just a geometrical
bending of spacetime.
So in some ways, we can
picture this, right?
We can take a fabric, put
four people on its corners,
stretch it out.
And then let's say we put
a cannonball at the center.
What do we expect?
We expect that fabric to bend.
So Einstein applied
the same principles
to now not just
the normal fabric,
but the fabric of
space and time,
and said, every
object with a mass--
let's say our sun--
bends, makes these curvatures
in the space and time around it.
So in this geometrical
formulation,
there are immediate
consequences.
If you bend the space
of fabric and time--
so let's go back to
our cannonball example.
Now take a small marble
and put it on that fabric.
What is it going to do?
It's going to go down that path.
It's going to follow
that spacetime,
except that that
spacetime will be curved.
So what Einstein said is that
not only matter, but light,
will also follow these
curvatures of spacetime.
So let's say that we are
sitting here on Earth.
We are looking behind our sun.
The sun has bent the paths of
all the light coming to us,
which means that a star that is
actually here and emitting its
light in all directions-- and
some of it reaches us here
on Earth--
has to follow this
down and back up
of that curved
fabric of spacetime.
Now this is just like a lens.
If you put a glass of
water, it bends the light
that goes through that water.
So what's the net result?
An observer sitting
here on Earth
would think that
the light actually
came from here, because we just
follow it back in its path.
And we would think that
the star is actually
here because of that
bending of light.
Kind of strange, is it true?
So this is now 1915.
Einstein formulated
this entire theory
that explained
some of the things
that Newton's theory of
gravity couldn't explain.
But there was no
experimental evidence
that this was actually what
was going on until Sir Arthur
Eddington took advantage
of a solar eclipse
in order to arrange an
expedition to a small island
off the west coast of Africa.
And here is what they did.
I know this is a
little bit hard to see,
but it's the original image.
So I wanted to
share that with you.
This is now 1919.
And what they say is
that, OK, if the sun
is in our line of sight, and we
are looking at stars behind it,
then we should see this
shift in their position,
in the perceived
location of those stars.
Now when the sun
is up in the sky,
obviously we can't see
the stars behind it.
That's why the solar
eclipse was so important.
It blocked the
light from the sun
for six minutes, enough for them
to see where those stars are.
And they compared this to
data taken six months prior
when the sun was on the other
side of the Earth's orbit.
And they saw--
I don't know if you
can make it out--
this shift in the positions
of stars in the sky.
This one is not visible, but
hopefully you can see these.
So this is data combined from
the solar eclipse with those
taken six months
apart, when the sun was
in the other direction,
when it wasn't
giving this curvature to the
spacetime in front of us.
So this became instant success
because seeing is believing.
And it was on the cover of all
major publications of the time.
Basically, the day after Sir
Arthur Eddington took the data,
Einstein became an
instant success.
And this is the cover of "The
New York Times" from 1919.
And "men of science
more or less agog over
results of eclipse observation."
So basically, it changed
people's world view,
that, yes, this geometrical
formulation of gravity
is the right one.
And Einstein's
theory is correct.
So if it naturally
predicts this what
we call gravitational lensing
in the sense that paths of light
are bent and masses act like
lenses, just like the lenses
that we know that make
things look distorted,
so if this gravitational
lensing happens,
then we should be able to see
it elsewhere in the universe.
And, indeed, we do.
One of the places that
we see this beautifully
is clusters of galaxies where
there is so much mass packed
into a small volume that all the
background galaxies are lensed.
And this is a Hubble
Space Telescope image.
Showing the giant blue arc.
It's also called
an Einstein ring.
This is actually one
galaxy that happens to be
behind this galaxy cluster.
And because light is now coming
to us from all directions,
encompassing that
galaxy cluster,
we see it as a ring in the
sky, even though it's one point
object behind this cluster.
So gravitational
lensing happens.
Take this to its
next logical step.
Now I have a neutron star.
I have packed so much
matter into a small volume,
it's going to curve
the spacetime around it
pretty drastically.
What if I cross that one extra
step and put so much matter in
that now it's
collapsing inwards,
and all the light
paths are bent inwards?
I mean, all the light paths.
There is no light that's
approaching that object that
can make its way out.
So they are lensed inwards
so much that they're
absorbed by that mass.
That is what we
call a black hole.
Let me just show you, if we
were able to take our journey
physically into a black
hole, what our computer
simulations, actual
calculations,
would show as far as what
our journey would look like.
So we are going to
now in the next movie
that I'm going to show you
dive into a black hole.
On the lower-left corner, you're
going to see our trajectory.
We are not going straight.
We are kind of
taking a swirly path.
And we're going to cross
that point of no return
called the event horizon, OK?
And even though it looks like
the black hole is moving,
actually what's happening
is we are moving.
This is our trajectory,
and this is just
a grid painted on there.
Of course, you wouldn't
see this if you
were falling into a black
hole, but it's there just
to make it clear.
But it's there to show
you that, for example, you
would see the two poles
of a sphere at once
because everything
is bent inwards.
And we are approaching
the horizon.
The red circle here
is the horizon.
Look at what happens.
All the lines that
were behind us
and all the lines that
were in front of us
now collapse into one.
We are now in the singularity.
So it would look
something like this.
And if I could, I
would go and enjoy it.
I wouldn't be able
to report back
to you what it looked like.
And I don't think I can convince
a graduate student to go.
So we are going to do
the next best thing.
We can't go there, but we know
what a black hole should do
to any light that is around it.
And we've known this
since the '70s actually.
There are calculations,
literally hand-drawn diagrams
and long pages of
calculations, calculus,
that people have carried
out as far back as 1973
to tell us the telltale
signature of a black hole.
There is something
that is uniquely
predicted by the
existence of a black hole.
And that is that shadow, that
silhouette that it leaves
on the light surrounding it.
In the early calculations, the
pen-and-paper calculations,
they imagined a source of
light, somebody kindly holding
a flashlight behind
the black hole for us
and what it would look like
if this was a black hole,
what it should look like if
we could take a picture of it.
And what they said
is that there should
be a bright ring of light.
And interior to it, there
should be absolute darkness.
That is the telltale signature.
It's a shadow.
It's a silhouette.
And that would define
that point, that presence
of the event horizon
where we are disconnected
from the universe, where
the rest of the black hole
is disconnected
from the universe.
Again, why are we
looking for this?
Let's think back to
some of our questions.
We now want evidence
that this actually
happens, not just
gravitational lensing happens,
not just that the
photon paths are bent.
This is a logical conclusion
of general relativity.
It's almost inevitable.
And yet at the same
time, it is so bizarre.
It is bizarre because
it's predicting regions
of the universe that are
completely disconnected
from the other regions, that
information goes in but doesn't
come back out.
And, two, it actually
contradicts everything else
that we know about particle
physics because in particle
physics, where we formulate
things as an interaction,
as a force, what we say is
that if I combine two particles
and make a third one, the
reverse reaction should always
be possible, too.
It may not happen often,
but it should be possible.
If I go in this
direction, I should be
able to go in this direction.
Clearly, that's
breaking down here.
I can go in, but I
can't come back out.
So if I now try to write
the laws of particle physics
around the event horizon,
I get nonsensical results.
Again, our theories are
clashing with each other.
Even though they are
individually well tested,
they are taking us
to a place where
it might be fruitful
to really look at,
is physics breaking down?
Do we have to rethink reality?
That's what's so
attractive about looking
around black holes and
looking for signatures
of this black hole
event horizon.
As time went on,
in about year 2000
we started doing more
realistic calculations
where somebody didn't have to
hold the flashlight for us.
But the source of the
light was actually
the hot gas that's swirling
around the black hole itself.
Because black holes
have such a strong pull,
they pull gas from
stars or clouds
or whatever might cross
their path around them.
And as this matter swirls
around and makes its way
towards the black
hole, it heats up
because it's gaining
so much energy
from this gravitational field
that it heats up and starts
emitting light.
So we started being
able to do somewhat more
realistic calculations
right around the year 2000,
and this is one of those images.
Now instead of a donut
like you see on this one,
this is more a crescent.
The reason for that is the
light is no longer uniformly
coming from the back.
But it's coming from the
swirling, hot plasma, which
means that the part that's
moving towards the observer
is brighter.
And the part, just
like an ambulance siren
that is higher pitch when it
comes towards you and lower
pitch as it's going
away from you,
one side becomes
brighter than the other.
So instead of
looking for a donut,
we should really be
looking for a crescent.
It still has this other
side, but it should really
be brighter here.
Now since the year 2000,
a lot has happened.
And a lot has happened both on
the experimental side, where
we actually started
a campaign to take
a picture of a black
hole, and on the theory
side, where we had to know what
really we were looking for.
Everything that I've
shown you so far
has been highly idealized.
So if you want us to
now take this concept--
that is look for the
shadow of a black hole,
take a picture of it, and apply
it to a real-life experiment--
you would fail, because
of all the complexities
you haven't taken into account.
So what we have done here
at the University of Arizona
is develop new computational
techniques, new algorithms,
that allow us to do these
calculations millions
of times faster than it
has been possible before.
And, in fact, it has
been such a breakthrough
that I want to show you not an
animation that we did with it,
but a movie of one of our
research associates, CK Chan,
actually running the
simulation in real time.
And we filmed him
running the simulation.
What made that possible?
What made it possible is that
little graphics processor unit
that you have on your
phones, on your laptops.
Instead of the
CPU, we now started
using the graphics card, GPUs.
And it's almost like
writing a computer game,
except that it's not.
It's solving the equations
of general relativity.
But making use of that graphics
processor unit, as I said,
we sped it up many, many
orders of magnitude.
So what you're going to
see here is this hand.
And there is a
motion sensor device
that's sitting right here.
We programmed it so it
would read hand gestures
like your Wii or Xbox.
And this is the black hole.
And he's going to shoot a
million photons, a million rays
of light, at this
black hole all at once.
So let's see.
He's initialising
the simulation.
He's running time forward.
So you see that wall of
light running and being
rendered visually in real time.
Now we can zoom in and look at
all the light that's already
trapped around this black hole.
Their paths have been changed.
Some of them already went in.
Some of them are just circling
around the black hole,
depending on how
close they came to it.
Running time forward again,
and now running time backward.
Why not?
We are allowed to
do that, right?
It's a computer simulation.
So now he's going
to zoom back out.
And you're going to see the
effect of this black hole
on this.
So these are all
the light rays that
traveled a little bit
longer and got left behind.
And when we run time
backwards and zoom out,
there it is, the shadow
of the black hole.
Now again, this is
highly idealized,
but I want you to understand
that this is running
on his laptop, on a single GPU.
And our goal is to be able
to scale this up and really
look at swirling, hot
plasma around a black hole
and calculate this
for every situation
that we can think of
and in order to take it
from this realm of theory into
what is really experimentally
visible.
So in order to do
that, of course,
we couldn't rely on
individual GPUs on laptops.
So the University of
Arizona, a number of us,
applied for the National
Science Foundation grant.
And we brought a GPU cluster
to the University of Arizona
that we lovingly named
El Gato, the cat.
And that was a
major breakthrough.
Even this amount of investment
in computational facilities,
in hardware, in theory,
really gives enormous results.
With this, we were number seven
for a small period of time
on the world's Green500 list,
meaning the highest number
of computations you
can do with the least
amount of energy spent.
These glories don't last very
long in the computer world,
but so we were super happy to
be number seven in the world
here at the U of A.
[APPLAUSE]
And this allowed us to
really scale up our game
and, as I said, take it
from that realm of this
is what general
relativity predicts--
this is what our theory
of gravity predicts-- to,
OK, let's turn this
into a real experiment.
And I'm going to skip this.
So what do you need
in order to take
a picture of that shadow of the
event horizon of a black hole?
You need a few things
to go in your favor.
First one, it's kind of obvious.
You want the Earth's
atmosphere to be transparent.
You know some
wavelengths of light
can't penetrate
through our atmosphere,
so we would like to
do this experiment
at a wavelength
that can actually
make it through our atmosphere.
We want the galaxy
to be transparent.
We are going to be looking
for nearby black holes
and the light emitted from
them to look for this crescent
or donut.
And we are going to
snap a picture of it.
So if the light
doesn't make it to you
between the black hole
and your telescopes,
then you're not going
to get a good picture,
as every photographer knows.
There is another component.
We have been talking about
this hot gas swirling
around a black hole.
And what if that
obscures your view?
So you need to pick a wavelength
where you have enough light so
that there is this
shadow forming
against that backdrop of
light, but it's not so much
that it's obscuring your view.
You need to be able to see down.
So this is one of
the simulations
that we've done using El Gato.
What you are going
to see is we are
going to change the
wavelength at which we
are looking at the black hole.
Initially, you'll see this
huge plasma blocking our view.
And as I run this forward
and increase the frequency,
or decrease the
wavelength at which we're
observing the black
hole, what you'll see
is at right around 1 millimeter
this crescent appearing here.
So three requirements-- the
atmosphere to be transparent,
1 millimeter actually
fulfills that criteria.
The galaxy to be
transparent, 1 millimeter
is a good wavelength to look at.
And the plasma
around the black hole
to be transparent
so that all you see
is that crescent, 1
millimeter fulfills that.
So it's a very
lucky coincidence.
And we've been working,
again, with all
of these types of simulations
at very large scales in order
to look at any complexity
that might come our way.
So there is a
fourth requirement,
which I didn't write down,
but it's kind of obvious.
This thing that
you're looking for
should be big enough in the
sky for you to be able to see.
So you might think, well,
where is the closest
black hole that we know of?
Is that what we're going after?
There are about 30 black holes
that we know of in our galaxy
that we definitively
know through other means,
for example, stars
circling around them,
that they are black holes.
Most of them, all except one,
tend to be about 10 times
the mass of our sun.
So they are kind of close,
but they are very, very small,
which means that
the size in the sky
is not something
that we can measure.
But there is one black
hole at the center
of our galaxy, the
center of Milky Way,
called Sagittarius A star,
Sag A star for short.
And that one, even though
it's farther away--
it's all the way at the
center of our galaxy--
it actually fulfills
the requirement
of being large enough
to be visible to us
as long as you have an
Earth-sized telescope.
How hard can that be?
OK, so our best target
is Sagittarius A star.
It's shadow size,
for those of you
who actually know the
sizes of things in the sky,
is 50 microarcseconds.
How tiny is that?
That's like putting a donut
on the moon and saying,
take a picture of it.
That's how big it is in the sky.
But again, if you have
an Earth-sized telescope,
that's OK.
You can do it.
Unfortunately, the
National Science Foundation
gives us money for El Gato,
but for some reason not
for an Earth-sized telescope.
So we go to the next
best alternative,
which is we pretend we have
an Earth-sized telescope.
What that means
is that we hook up
telescopes that are
scattered across the Earth
and use a technique
called interferometry.
The name doesn't matter.
All it means is
that you are looking
at a distant
object, in this case
your crescent with your shadow.
And you're looking at it with
telescopes across the Earth
at the same time.
And you're recording
your signals
with such high precision,
with an atomic clock, which
are the hydrogen-maser
clocks that
are at each radio telescope.
And you are recording
so much data
as these wavefronts come
in and hit your telescope
that after the fact you
can take these data drives,
and you can combine them and
look for a signal of where
they match up.
Where they match up, you
get this booming signal
that tells you how big was
the object that emitted it.
It's like treating the
Earth like a telescope dish.
Obviously, you're not going
to have the collecting
power of that dish,
but you're going
to have the resolving
power of that dish.
So we then send this to
correlators, right now
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts, and there
is a backup one in Germany.
And we've been building this
Event Horizon Telescope, both
the array and the collaboration
and all the data analysis tools
and the theory,
for about 15 years,
starting in the year 2000.
And Arizona has been
involved since the beginning,
not just for the
theoretical calculations
that I already told
you about, but also
because of our submillimeter
telescope, this telescope that
allows us to do the
1-millimeter observations right
here in Arizona.
So the array over
the 15 years has
grown to include these
9 telescopes that
span the Earth from
the South Pole,
to the Atacama Desert in Chile,
to Mexico, to Arizona, Hawaii,
and a couple of
stations in Europe.
And some of the dishes existed.
Other ones we had to outfit.
And here is the principle
that we are operating under.
We are going to look at
as the Earth rotates,
we are going to be looking
at it with as many subsets
of these nine dishes as
we can at any given time,
record the data, and
then combine it in order
to form the picture
after the fact
and see if the shadow
is there and if it's
as big as general
relativity tells us it is.
It's a very clean
experiment in some ways.
There is no wiggle room.
The donut needs to be
there, the crescent,
and it needs to be
a particular size.
So for some of the
telescopes, the dish
was there but the
appropriate receiver
that we needed to use
in order to record
the data were not there.
This is another U of A
contribution to the Event
Horizon Telescope.
My colleague Dan
Maroney's lab here
in the astronomy department,
he's a professor.
And he and his team have
built the millimeter receiver
for the South Pole
telescope, all shiny.
I mean, obviously how
beautiful is this gold?
It's a very good conductor.
So it just keeps the temperature
uniform across this receiver
and reduces the
noise that you get.
And I just like it
because it's shiny.
So he wants to know why
he let's me in his lab,
and I look at it, but not
anymore because they have taken
it down to the South Pole.
This is now Dan on a balmy day.
He's thrown off his jacket.
And this is how we treat
our graduate students.
This is Jun Han
Kim, who slaved away
on this instrument for
about three years now.
It's really a beautiful
success story.
And this is the purple cover
that they put on that receiver.
They are installing it in the
South Pole Telescope Dish.
The South Pole Telescope Dish
does many other experiments,
but it is part of the Event
Horizon Telescope Array,
now with the addition
of this receiver.
They did some testing.
This is between the APEX
and the Atacama Desert, one
of the telescopes that is in
the array, and the South Pole
Telescope.
And as I said, when it works,
when the two stations can
record the data faithfully and
then combine it after the fact,
this is the kind of
signal that you get.
And obviously, this has
been a success story.
So what we expect to see
for Sagittarius A star,
this is now a movie
rather than a still.
Because of the plasma
swirling around,
there are some fluctuations
in the brightness that we see.
But ultimately, that
crescent is always there.
So now if I combine
all of these images
and show you what the computer
simulation should look like,
and now pretend that this was
processed through all nine
stations and recombines.
Then this is what the
expected data looks like.
We are all ready.
We are ready from the getting
the nine stations ready point
of view.
We are ready from the data
analysis point of view.
And our first full
array observation
is going to be in the
first week of April.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Keep your fingers
crossed because we need
good weather in nine stations.
And if we can't get
it all this time,
obviously we are going to keep
on doing this experiment now
that all our tools are ready.
But April is around the corner.
I'm going to be at the SNT,
even though I'm not needed.
I just want to be there.
And hopefully, we are going
to come up with something
that either proves the
theory of relativity
or, even better, maybe
conflicts with it,
maybe shows us some signs of
where we should be looking
when we rethink reality again.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]